[موسيقى]
طب تم طلبات او قناتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار
الساعه نبداها بابرز العناوي
في اوكرانيا الظلام يتسع والسلام يبتعد
روسيا ترفع وتيره التصعيد مع الغرب وتتحدث
عن مواجهه المحتمله
بعد 34 عاما على تفجير اللوكربي كيف وصل
صانع القنبله ابو عجيل مسعود الى سجون
امريكا
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على المصالح
ومجالات التعاون بين واشنطن ودول الخليج
ستظل قويه رغم الاختلافات
[تصفيق]
والاضرابات المستمره والعزله الدوليه
العمله تنهار
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله
روسيا توعدت ويبدو انها بالفعل نفذت وصعدت
ميدانيا كثفت ميدانيا موسكو القصف في
اوكرانيا ووصلت استهداف منشاه الطاقه
لتدخل اجزاء واسعه من البلاد في اسوا
انقطاع للكهرباء اما سياسيا فلسفه موسكو
اي فرصه للحوار مع الغرب والصالح جهه
التصعيد التي انتهجتها على اكثر من صعيد
حيث اعلنت الرئاسه الروسيه اليوم ان
العلاقه بين روسيا والغرب وصلت لمرحله
المواجهه مع توسعه واستمرار الدعم العسكري
الذي وصفه المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
بمثل بسكو بغير المحدود لاوكرانيا
لروسيا للسلام وهذا ما اكد عليه وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر اليوم وقال
انه لم يراعيه مؤشرات على ان موسكو تدخل
في مفاوضات بنيه حسنه حذر كليفر لي من ان
اي محادثات السلامه في اوكرانيا يجب الا
تكون مجرده ستار لاعاده روسياسن
ثقه في ان فلاديمير بوتين سيدخل هذه
المحادثات بحسنينيه لا يزال الخطاب السائد
تصادمي ولكن في النهايه كما اقول نريد ان
رحل هذا الامر نفضل حله
عاجلاسيه ايضا تصريحات الرئيس الروسي
السابق هو نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الذي اكد ان بلاده تكذب اقوى وسائل
التدمير ولوحه باستخدامها ضد الغرب
انتكاسات عسكريه روسيه في الاشهر الاخيره
في اوكرانيا اعاده موسكو لمربع التلويح
بترسانتها النوويه في محاوله لتغيير وضعها
الميدانيه عدونا ليس متواجدا في الخنادق
فقط في محافظتك انه موجود في اوروبا
وامريكا الشماليه واليابان واستراليا
ونيوزيلندا وغيرها لهذا نقوم بتكثيف انتاج
اقوى وسائل التدمير
روسيا تقول انها ستلجا لمبادئ جديده لم
توضحها لكن الحديث على الاغلب يدور حول
تكتيك الترهيب الروسي بشبح الحرب النوويه
في محاوله لفرض صفقه مع الغرب الرئيس
الروسي بلادي مربوط باستخدامه تحت ذريعه
ان السلاح النوويه يعد وسيله دفاع الغايه
منها توجيه ضربه الانتقاميه في حال
استهدفت بلاده بهذا النوع من الاسلحه
وروسيا تعملوا على تعديل عقيدتها العسكريه
بالاعتماد على الاجيال الجديده من الاسلحه
التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت حسب البيانات
المعلنه للتسلح النووي العالمي منها التي
نشرتها منظمه ايكان فان روسيا تمتلك اكبر
ترسانه نوويه في العالم اذ يبلغ عدد
الرؤوس النوويه الحربيه لديها
6,255 راس نووويا منها
1588 جاهزا للاطلاق معظمها صواريخ موجهه
لاهداف بعيده المدى وعدد اخر اصغر حجما
واقل تدميرا تستهدف الاهداف قصيره المدى
في ساحه المعركه او في البحر
وسط التلميح النووي الروسي الدول الغربيه
تقف منجده باستخفاف روسيا بخطوره الوضع
محضره نياها بعدم استغلال محادثات سلام
اوكرانيا كغطاء لاعاده التسلح او التخطيط
لهجوم اكبر
فوكس الباحث فيها شؤون العسكريه والامنيه
اهلا بك سيد فوكس هل وصلت
المحادثات
يعني انجاز التعبير الى مرحله حوار من لا
يسمع بين الطرفين
نعم هو الجواب البسيط والقصير لانها لم
يتوصل الى اساس او ارضيه
مشتركه بامكانهما الاتفاق عليها
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني اشار اليوم الى
ان العمليات العدائيه مستمره
والمستشار شولتس الالماني السيد بوتن
يحاول التشبه
بما استولى عليه الجنود الروسيا داخل
اوكرانيا منذ فبراير
وبربما للمزيد من الاراضي او من اعتقه
اضافيه ولكنني يجب ان اقول
اعتقد بانما يحاول بوتن القيام به الان هو
التسبب باقصى حالات اللمس والتجويش في
العالم الدبلوماسي
بينما هو في الحقيقه يفكر فيما سيقوم به
لاحقا وخطواته التاليه طيب اليوم حينما
نتحدث بان هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يتم
تلويح بها للمواجهه ولكن كان هناك خطوط
اتصال بين الطرفين ولا ربما تحت سقف
السلام حتى لا نصل الى المواجهه النوويه
ما الذي تغير
حاجات تجيبين
بعد
فالديه حيل اخرى
بامكانه استخدامها
تطورات غريبه مثلا وضع الاستيحه الدفاع
الجوي في منطقه سفر روسيا ومحيطه بمحطه
نوويه في زفره
باي بلاي ستيشن
350 الف شخص
المنتصر في شهر فبراير وهذا خطر جدا
واعتقد بان هذا يوضح ويعبر عن بعض
التبجح والتفاخر بالقوه العسكريه الروسيه
الا انه ضعيف همم
اجتماعيا واقتصاد بين الحجر ولا يستطيع ان
يحصل الاشياء التي يرغب بها همم
التكنولوجيا لاغلب
ترسانتيه العسكريه نعم
مثل لاعب الورق ويتخبط ولا اعرف ما هي
خطوه التاليه ليس رجل استراتيجي لانني في
هذه الخطوه لا ارى اي وجهه واضحه لتحركاته
بعد ثلاث حركاته او اربع حركات مستقبلا
شكرا يا سيد روبرت فوق الباحث فيها شغل
العسكريه والامنيه
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا الجنوب الاوكراني يغرق في الظلام
والكهرباء تتحول الى عمله نادره القصف
الروسي المتواصل تسبب في انقطاع الكهرباء
عن جميع مرافق البنيه التحتيه غير الحيويه
في مدينه وادي السير الساحليه بجنوب
اوكرانيا الهجوم الروسيه تم بواسطه
الطائرات مسيره ايرانيه وادى الى تدمير
منشئتين للطاقه ما تسبب في انقطاع
الكهرباء عن مليون ونصف مليون شخص ليعدى
اسوا انقطاع للكهرباء في اوكرانيا
اليوتيوب
القضيه الرئيسيه اليوم هي الطاقه الوضع في
منطقه اوديسا صعب للغايه بعد الضربه
الليليه التي شنتها طائره ايرانيه بدون
طياره يخيم الظلام على اوديسا ومدن وقرى
اخرى في المنطقه وحتى الان اكثر من مليون
شخص في منطقه اوديسا بدون كهرباء
وما ترزح تحته بعض اجزاء اوكرانيا من ظلام
السلم ياتي صدفه بل جاء بتخطيط الروسي
بشكل صريح منذ اسابيع وموسكو تستهدف
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا بموجات
كبيره من الضربات الصاروخيه والطائرات
المسيره التاكيد والاسباب لم تخفيها على
لساني اعلى سلطه في البلاد الرئيس الروسي
القديمه
حول استهداف البنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا
بالاجابه قائلا نعم نحن نفعل ذلك ولكن من
بداها من الذي ضرب جسر القرن تساءل الرئيس
الروسي
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
الاحتفالات مستمره بتاهل المنتخب المغربي
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله صفحته قضيه تفجير لك ربي لم
تطوى بعد فالقضيه دخلت اصلا جديده نوع مره
على وقوعها اكثر من ثلاثه عقود الجديد في
القضيه فجرتها السلطات الامريكيه
واسكتلنديه التي قالت ان المواطن الليبيه
الذي يشتبه في انه صنع القنبله التي دمر
الطائره الركاب
الاسكتلنديه محتجاز الان لدى الولايات
المتحده الجانبان كشف عن اسم المتهم
ويتعلق الامر بابو عجيله مسعود اعلان من
شانه ان يثير جدا كبيرا داخل ليبيا
وتساؤلات كيف وصل مسعود الى امريكا
اقفل بالكامل من الناحيه السياسيه
والقانونيه حسب الاتفاقيه التي ابرمت بين
واشنطن وطرابلس في العام 2008
[موسيقى]
هذا هو عبر مجلس الامن القومي الليبيه عن
استغرابه لمحاكمه ابو عجيله مسعوده في
امريكا على خلفيه في هجوم وقال مجلس الامن
القومي الليبي ان واشنطن تعهدت عام 2008
بانهاء اي مطالبات مرتبطه بهجوم لوكربي
وكان ابو عجيل مسؤولا بجهاز المخابرات في
عهد النظام الليبي السابق وتمت ادانته
بتهم لها علاقه بالحادث المميته الذي راح
ضحيته 270 شخصا من بينهم 190 امريكيه خلال
رحله طيران بين لندن
[موسيقى]
معنى من القاهره الصحفيه المختص في شان
الليبيه عبد الستار احتياطي السيد عبد
الستار اهلا بك يعني بعد ان وقعت الولايات
المتحده عام 2008 على هذه الاتفاقيه بعدم
المطالبه باي حيا لهذا الملك لماذا يخطف
هذا الرجل كما تقول عائلته هل لاغراض
سياسيه بالفعل ام هو ثائر
كل هذه همم الاشياء يعني اغراض سياسيه
وثار ايضا
الوضع في شمال غرب ليبيا وتحت سلطه
الحكومه المنتهه الولايه وفي ظل وجود
ميليشيات كثيره يعني يعطي مبرر او يجعل
الامور منطقيه اذا ما تم
نقل السيد بعجيله الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يعني هذا اعتقد انه منطقي الى
حد كبير بعيدا عن تفاصيل القضيه الجانب
الاخر المتعلق بغلق القضيه النظام القضائي
في الغرب عموما وفي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خصوصا هو معقد للغايه ولا يشبه
النظام القضائي في المنطقه العربيه او في
غالبيه الدول العربيه يعني يمكن لولايه من
الولايات او محكمه في دلاليه او المدعي في
اضرارالي ان يستمع الى شكوى حتى بعد مرور
سنين يستمع الى شكوى ويعيد التحقيق فيها
يعني يمكن ان تضيفي لهذا ان السيد همم بو
عقيله لم يكن موجود في القضيه ويمكن الزعم
بان اغلاق القضيه كان يتعلق به وجود عبد
الباسط المجراحي همم المدان من محكمه في
اسكتلندا حول تفجير الطائره في عام 88 وان
مسعود بعجله لا يشمله همم قرار همم
المصالحه او اغلاق القضيه ما بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والجانب الليبي اذا
ذهبنا الى الشقه السياسي بانها لاغراض
سياسيه ماذا تريد الولايات المتحده هل
الضغط على ليبيا ولماذا ماذا تريد
هو الموضوع طبعا قديم يعني الموضوع بعجيله
ذكر اسمه منذ عام 88 في التحقيقات الخاصه
بعبد الباسط المجراحي لكن يبدو ان السلطات
لم السلطات القضائيه يعني التي تحقق في
القضيه لم تكن تعرف عنه شيئا الى عام 2012
حين بدا تحقيق معه على ايدي يعني جماعات
من الشاويه في طرابلس
وتواصلت هذه التحقيقات بخط يد اا بعجيله
حسب النظام المدعيين الامريكيين بخط يتبع
ليله وصلت الى الجانب الامريكي في عام
2016 اليوم اا هناك اطراف كثيره تحاول ان
تتربح منها كذا قضيه دون حتى التحقيق
المتاني في المزعم الموجوده بخط يد بعجيله
منها طبعا بجانب الامريكي يريد ان يستمر
في الضغط على الليبيين لاسباب خاصه
اقتصاديه بالاساس تتعلق بالنفط والغاز
كذلك الحكومه حكومه السيد عبد الحميد بيبي
من ثلاث الو تريد ان تحقق مكاسب من اجل
اطاله عمرها وكسب الرضا الغربي ورضا
الامريكي وعدم المطالبه برحيلها واشياء
نظر قبيل يعني هناك اطراف كثيره حتى
الاطراف المليشاويه تحاول بعضها ان تكسب
رضا الامريكان ورد الغرب ورده ال- همم بعض
الاطراف في الامم المتحده حتى لا تقع
عليها عقوبات او يتم اعفاءه من بعض
الملاحقات يعني الكل يحاول ان يكسب من هذه
القضيه التي انا اقول لاني قراءه ال- همم
التحقيقات التي جرت مع السيد ابو عقيله
همم لا يمكن همم
اتهامه وفقا لديه تحقيقات كان ينبغي قبل
القبض عليه وقبل النقل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التحقيق في التفاصيل الدقيقه
التي ذكرها نعم نعم
جزيلا للمختصر في اشياء الليبيه عبد
الستار احت- كنت معنا من القاهره
[موسيقى]
هكذا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على استعداد
المملكه الدائم للتعامل مع مختلف الادارات
المتعاقب المتعاقبه على الحكم في الولايات
المتحده سواء تعلق الامر بالجمهوريين او
الديمقراطيين وقال في مؤتمر السياسات
الدوليه في ابو ظبي ان امريكا لها دور مهم
في المنطقه ولكن هناك حاجه لحوار
الاستراتيجيا حقيقي حقيقي
والسياسات مختلفه بين الاداره الجمهوريه
والديمقراطيه لكن في الختام المصالح
الامريكيه هي نفسها فربما تكون مقاربتهم
اتجاه هذه المصالح مختلفه جمعتنا علاقات
قويه جدا مع اميريكا عبر ادارات مختلفه
جمهوريه وديمقراطيه واعتدنا التعامل مع
هذا الاختلاف اعتقد ان المصالح المشتركه
ستبقى مستمره في المستقبل وستهم مجالات
التعاون بين المملكه والخليج والولايات
المتحده
فيما يتعلق بالنزاع بين روسيا واوكرانيا
شدد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان على ضروره حل النزاع بالحوار
مشيرا الى ان علاقه المملكه مع روسيا سهمت
في الافراج عن سجناء من اوكرانيا وامريكا
اما فيما يتعلق بايران فحذر وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه من ان فشل الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران سيدخل المنطقه في مرحله خطيره جدا
ودعاء الى ضروره معالجه نقاط
هناك فرصه لكن هل التوصل الى اتفاق النووي
يعني ان ايران لن تصبح دوله النوويه ولن
يكون لديها سلاح نووي لا اعرف انا اشك نحن
نستمر بدعم التفاعل عبر الاتفاق النووي
وخطه عمل مشتركات ولكن هذه نقطه بدايه
وليست نقطه نهايه لمعالجه بعض نقاط الضعف
في الاتفاق البوادر غير ايجابيه سمعنا من
الايرانيين ان ليس لديهم اي مصلحه في
برنامج اسلحه النوويه ولكننا بحاجه الى
مزيد من الضمانات واذا لم نصل الى اتفاق
النووي سندخل في مرحله معقده جدا
وعلينا ان نتجنبها حتى لو عدنا الى اتفاق
النووي لست متاكدا من انها الخطوه
النهائيه بل يجب ان نبحث فيما بعد التوصل
الى اتفاق اقوى
[موسيقى]
ثيران لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت الاحتجاجات
المتواصله ليل نهار العديد من المناطق
البلاد شهدت تظاهرات الليليه في تبريز
الاهواز وايضا في العاصمه طهران هذا هو
هجمت قوات الامن الايرانيه محتجين في
منطقه ستار خان وواسطه العاصمه طهران
للتمديد باعدام محسن شكاري وذكرت تقارير
ان المتظاهرين في منطقه
النظام قاتل الاطفال
السلام عليكم
على الوضع الاقتصادي في ايران بتراجع قيمه
الريال الايراني الذي بلغ ادنى مستوى
منخفض جديد مقابل الدولار فقد تم بيع
الدولار بما يصل الى 370 الفا 2200 ريال
ايراني في السوق يغير الرسميه وكان الريال
حوالي 14% من قيمته منذ اندلاع الاحتجاجات
على مستوى البلاد قد فقد هذه القيمه
هذه هي سمه المدن الاراديه تظاهرات
متواصلات تحيط بالنظام وتضرب اقتصاد
البلاد المنهل في مقتل في خضم عقوبات تلو
اخرى
ليتراجع الريال الايراني المتعثر الى
مستوى منخفض جديد مقابل الدولار مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات والاضرابات العماليه
والاسواق وتزايد عزله البلاد وسط
الانتقادات الغربيه
للاجراءات الامنيه الصارمه التي يتخذها
النظام تجاه المحتجين حيث كان يتم بيع
الدولار بما يصل الى 300,000 ريال في ما
ارتفع بعد الاحتجاجات الى اكثر من
370,000 ريال
وفقد الريال قرابه 14% من قيمته منذ
اندلاع الاحتجاجات على مستوى البلاد عقب
مقتل سامي
قفزه كبيره انعكست هي الاخرى على ارتفاع
الاسعار مع عدم قدره النظام على دفع رواتب
المتقاعدين ما دفع بهم للتجمع في وقفات
احتجاجيه اضافه الى اضرابات في قطاعات
النفط والغاز
والبتروكيماويات في المحافظات الجنوبيه
احتجاجا على الغلاء والظروف المعيشيه
الصعبه والتاخر في دفع الرواتب
التحام التظاهرات بالاضرابات ذلك ما يخشاه
النظام الايراني الامر الذي قد يؤدي الى
شل البلاد وحركتها الاقتصاديه المناكه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
معنا من لندن عارف ناصر الباحث في شان
الايرانيه سيد عارفها امريكا بدايه اذا
استمرت هذه الاحتجاجات الى اطول من هذه
المده كيف سيؤثر ذلك على الوضع الاقتصادي
في ايران وبالتالي ما الذي يمكن ان ينتج
عنه ذلك
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهدين العربيه الكرام
انا اعتقد بان هذه الاحتجاجات
لها اثر الجسيم وخاصه الاضرابات العامه
وبالتالي همم جانب الاقتصادي او الضغط
الذي يحاول الشعب من خلال الاحجام من
الشراء او اغلاق المحل التجاريه اي يريده
على الحكومه لكن بالتوازي مع ذلك عده نقاط
اخرى ايضا يجب ان ناخذها بعين الاعتبار
اهمها اعتقد بان موت همم السرير للاتفاق
النووي
الى جانب ذلك همم التوقعات بان ستكون
هنالك مجموعه من العقوبات الاوروبيه ايضا
ستلعب دور الحاسم بسعر الصرف همم المحل
للرياض كيف سيؤثر ذلك على النظام بحيث اذا
استمرت هذه الاحتجاجات هل من الممكن ان
بالفعل تصاب ايه ايران بشلل اقتصادي همم
همم يعني بالاضافه الى الاضطرابات التي
تقوم
بالفعل انا اعتقد بان هذا الامر يلعب دور
مهم جدا خاصه وان كل اليات همم البنك
المركزي الى مسك ربما ااه سعر الصرف
الريال الان استنفذت خلال سنوات الماضيه
وبالتالي هنالك همم ربما ااه اساليب
محدوده جدا للتعامل مع همم مع هذا الامر
زياده في القمع بالنسبه همم للنظام تقديم
تنازلات للشارع والمحتاجين
يعني اعتقد بغض النظر عن هذا الامر هنالك
احتاد بغض النظر عن عن ال ال ربما عنف
الحكومه سيكون هنالك الضغط اكثر مواد ما
دام سيكون الضغط اكثر سيكون غضب جماهير
اكثر تجاه الحكومه هنالك عده نظريات
بالعلوم السياسيه تفسر الثوره مثلا الثوره
عام 1979 احدى التفسيرات كانت هو منحني جي
يعني يعني ربما العامل المحفز للاقتصاد
الايراني عندما انهار همم عام 1979 ادى
الى غضب جماهيري وبالتالي ادت همم الى
تسارع عمليه الثوره نفس هذا الامر ممكن
تفسيره بما يحدث الان بمعنى ربما همم عامل
همم
العقوبات الدوليه سيؤدي يؤدي بالفعل الى
غضب جماهيره وبالتالي فعاليه همم اقل
الحكومه الايرانيه لذلك هذا الامر ممكن
اعتباره كعامل اساسي ممكن ان يؤدي الى
ازدياد حجم الغضب الجماهيري من عدم
فعاليات الحكومه طيب الشارع الايراني هل
سيتحمل ذلك الارتفاع في بالتاكيد سيرتفع
في قيمه الاستهلاك او حتى انخفاض القوه
الشرائيه
اليوم صحيفه شرق الايرانيه اشترت تقرير
مهم جدا اعتقد بانه يستطيع ان يجيب على
هذا الامر وهو ان الايرانيين الان باتوا
يبيعون اثاث منزلهم مقابل زيت الطعام او
همم الرز
وكذلك البنك المركزي اشار بان هنالك
ارتفاع
68% ل- همم المواد الغذائيه همم في العام
الماضي وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل بان همم
القدره الشرائيه لل- همم
المجتمع الايراني جدا وبالتالي انا اعتقد
بان هذا الامر سوف يؤدي الى الاحتقان
الشعبي كما اسلاك شكرا جزيلا يا سيد عارف
ناصر الباحث في شان الايراني منظرنا
نعم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد فوز اسود الاطلس على البرتغال بهدف
دون رد في كاس العالم بقطر حقق منتخب
المغرب مجموعه من الارقام القياسيه رافقت
انجازها تاريخي بالوصول الى نصف نهائي كاس
العالم نستعرض هنا قائمه بابرز الارقام
القياسيه التي حققها اسود الاطلس بفضل
مشوارهم المميز في المونديال حتى الان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واضمن اجواء هذا التاهل التاريخي للمنتخب
المغربي بعد فوزه على منتخب البرتغال
نتوقف مع تصريحات للنجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو الذي قال في تدوينه على
صفحته على الانستغرام ان حلمه بالفوز بكاس
العالم مع منتخب بلاده انتهى لكنه لم يعلن
اعتزاله اللعب الدوليه بشكل سريع
[موسيقى]
فصل وانا متابع اخبار الساعه
اهلا بكم
اعلن الجيش الباكستاني ان قوات من حرس
الحدود
الافغانيها كثيفه ما تسببها في مقتل سته
مدنيين واصابه 17 اخرين على الجانب
الباكستاني من الحدود وقال الجيش في بيان
له قوات الباكستانيه ردت باطلاق النار
في
الجنوب الغربي دون ذكر تفاصيل عن اي خسائر
في الجانب الاخر
[موسيقى]
اعلنت النيابه العامه لبلجيكيه توجيهي
تهملي اربعه اشخاص واحتجازه من استمرار
لتحقيق معهم في قضيه الفساد في البرلمان
الاوروبيه وقال مصدر قضائي للفرنسي ان ان
المتهمين من بينهم اذا كايلي وهي عضو في
البرلمان الاشتراكي اليوناني واحد نواب
رئيس البرلمان
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الحكومه الالمانيه اعتزامها تجديد
قوانين حيازه السلاح بعد المحاولات
الانقلابيه لحركه مواطن الرايخ وقالت
وزيره وزير الداخليه الالمانيه نانسي
ان هذه الحركه تمثل تحديدا متناميا للبلاد
نظرا لاتساع قاعدتها من 2000 الى 23,000
في العام الماضي واشاره الى مصادره اسلحه
من اكثر من 1000 من اعضاء الحركه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هيئته تنظيم قطاع النقل البريه في
الاردن عن توصلها لاتفاق مع نقابه النقابه
العامه لملكيه الحافلات الاردنيه والنقابه
العامه لاصحاب السيارات العموميه وسيارات
الاجره وجاء هذا الاتفاق بعد لقاء عقد في
وزاره النقل مع النقابتين وممثلين عن
القطاع تم خلاله التداول في زياده الدعم
النقدي لقطاع نقل الركاب مقابل رفع اجور
النقل على المواطنين وتقرر رفع او وقفه
كافه اشكال الاضراب في هذا القطاع مقابل
زياده الدعم النقدي لمده ثلاثه اشهر يتم
مراجعتها وتجديدها دوليا
[موسيقى]
اثار الى معسكر يستفيديو والمالك الجديد
لشركه تويتر الجدله في الاول من ديسمبر
عندما اعلن عن سلسله تغريدات حول الكشف عن
وثائق داخليه من الشركه نفسها اطلق عليها
ملفات تويتر واعلن قبل ساعه بالاشتراك مع
الصحفي مايكل سبيلر عن ملفات داخليه سلطت
الضوء على المراحل التي ادت الى حظر حساب
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب عن المنصه
كما وعد قبل اسابيع غرد الى الماسك الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه تويتر والصحفي ماكل شلن
برجر بالجزء الرابع من الملفات الداخليه
لعملاق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تصلي
الضوء على ما حصل في اليوم التالي لاحداث
السادس من يناير في مبنى الكابيتول هيل
برسالته قبل ساعه على المنصه والمعنونه
بازاله ترامب سبعه يناير
ظهر شلن برجر ان الرئيس التنفيذيه السابق
لشركه تويتر جاك دورسي كان في اجازه وفوض
الكثير من مسؤوليته الى رئيس الثقه
والسلامه السابق في تويتر
الموظفين على الاستمرار بالتمسك بالسياسه
منصه لان القررت اخذ لتعليق حساب ترامب
وبررت تويتر ذلك بانه تم تقييم اللغه في
تغريدات ترامب واعتبرت انها تنتهي كل
سياسه تمجيد العنف وان حساب الرئيس ترامب
بويقافه فورا ونهائيا من الخدمه
تغيير في السياسه لانه في حاجتين حصلت في
الفتره هذه اولا انه جاك دورسي ما كان
موجود في تويتر همم خلال الفتره دي فهو
كان خارج البلد ثانيا انه كان في ضغط من
الداخل ومن الخارج هذه الملفات ولم تمر
مرور الكرام لدى الحزب الجمهوري والفريق
القانوني لحزب المحافظين الذين اعتبروها
ادله تثبت المخاوف التي صرحوا عنها في عده
مناسبات حول كونهن ضحايا للقوائم السوداء
والمنع من التعليق والحج على المنصه على
عكس شهاده المدرنات تنفيذيين للشركات في
جلسات الاستماع في الكونغرس السابقه
من البيت الابيض سوف يكون له ولفريقه ورقه
يستعملها
ويعزز مواقع اذا تم الهجوم عليه قانونيا
او سياسيا فهو فهو لديه ورقه كبيره كبيره
يقول انا كنت تحت ضغط وتدخل الاجهزه
المركزيه او الخصم السياسي لترامب
وبالتالي هذا سوف يخلق بخ يعني بقناعه
واقعه جديد في العام الان هذه التسريباته
اظهرت كيف تم تغيير السياسه الداخليه لحظر
حساب الرئيس السابق ومنعه من التغريد على
المنصه واحده وبشكل متميز عن بقيه القاده
السياسيين الاخرين
حتى اللحظه خاصه مع سياسه عدم التعليق
التي انتهجها الرئيس دونالد ترامب حول
الموضوع برمته منذ اعلاني لهم ماسك من على
حضرتك حساباته حتى هذه المعلومات التي
ربما لم تكن خفيه لدى البعض ريتا سليمان
العربيه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
فترى عرض وثائقيه عن الامير هاري وزوجته
ميجا ماركل على منصه نتفليكس اثار الكثير
من الانتقادات سواء قد شلت عدد من الصحف
البريطانيه هجوما على الثنائي وذهب البعض
الى حد وصف ما جرى بالخيانه الملكيه
الاسبوعين الماضي
حادثه العنصريه التي طالت مساعده
حتى اعلنت منصه نتفليكس عن وثائقي هاري
ومجد هذا الوثائقي الذي تصدر عناوين الصحف
كافه بلا استثناء وهو ما قد يتسبب بصداع
للعائله الملكيه التي عاده ما تتجنب
الحديث في امور العائله الخاصه
طيب
مثل حلقات الثلاثه الاولى لا تقلوا عن ضجه
الاعلان الترويجي الذي تزامن مع زيارتي
ويليام وكيت الى امريكا فاراء الثنائي في
العائله الملكه ستنفرت مؤيدها لا سيما في
وسائل الاعلام
صحيفه المترو ذائعه الصيت والتي توزع في
القطارات سنه هجوما عنيفا على هاري وماجد
سائله اياهما هل تضعان المال قبل العائله
واجابت عنهما قائله انه السؤال الذي لن
يجيب عنه
صحيفه الديلي اكسبريس
صوره لهاري والملك الراحله طلبت بايقاف ما
وصفته بالخيانه للملكه الديل ميل والدليل
الملكه الراحله في حين تحدثت تايمز عن
انزعاج القصر من الوثائقي ومعتضمنه
يا بذلك
حمايه للملاحقه الاعلام لها بحجه ان هذا
ما يحدث لكل اللواتي يرتبط بالعائله
ويتحدث هاري عن فخره بان اطفاله مختلطوا
العرق وكيف انه فعل مثل ماذا وترك كل شيء
لاجلها
النقمه على العائله حيث تقول انها مهما
فعلت كانوا شيء يجدون طريقه لتدميرها في
الوثائقي يبدو هاري ماخودا بوالدته وبتشبه
بينها وبين من حيث التعاطف والحنان ومن
حيث الثقه والدفء هل يقول انه سيفعل ما
بيوسعه لتجنب تكرار سيناري والدته مع
عائلته الحاليه هو لا يريد للتاريخ ان
يعيد نفسه وربما ذلك هو المفتاح الذي
ادخله القلوب الكثيرين الذين احبه دائما
[موسيقى]
هبطت مركبه اوريون نبي سلام في المحيط
الهادي بعد رحله تجريبيه الى القمر ووفقه
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناس فان هذه
التجربه في المستقبل القريب الطريقه امام
رواد الفضاء في الرحلات الى القمر وجاء
هبوط المركبه اوريون على الارض بالتزامني
مع ذكر الخمسين لهبوطي ابولو 17 اخر مركبه
فضاء تحمل بشر وصلت الى القمر قبل 50 عاما
الى العمل
في اوكرانيا الظلام يتسع وسلام يبتعد
روسيا ترفع وتيره التصعيد مع الغرب وتتحدث
عن مواجهه محتمله
بعد 34 عاما على تفجير لوكربي كيف وصل
صانع القنبله ابو عجيل مسعود الى سجون
ليبيا
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه المصالح هو مجالات
التعامل بين واشنطن ودول الخليج ستظل قوي
يا رغم الاختلافات
النظام الايراني في مازق جديد بعد
الاحتياج الاحتجاجات والاضرابات المستمره
والعزله الدوليه العمله تنهار
شكرا لطيب المتابعه والقاكم على راس
الساعه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]